[Music]
hey rob this is kevin from ontario
canada calling i my question is i know
you're a big sports fan i'm a big sports
fan as well i love figuring out rosters
and also teams and things like that so
my question for you is this
if you were to construct a movie
and you could pick anybody in the world
only living
who would be the director who would be
the composer
who would be your first co-star and
second co-star and what would the genre
be and you could throw in any extras you
want there but uh those are the bases
what will be the perfect movie that you
would be in thank you
wow that's such a good question so fun
oh my gosh and equally as hard to answer
as who's your starting five all time in
basketball or
who's the best in field if you could
pick it which i do all the time this is
what i do on the set of 911 lone star i
sit around with my my friends on the
crew we have these conversations
so okay here we go is it martin scorsese
directing is it spielberg directing is
it paul thomas anderson
there's so many different people it
could be
um and you're never gonna go wrong with
a lot of them so i'm just gonna go with
what my instinct at the moment told me
so it's not even about what
would make the best movie really it's
about what i want to do
so with that being said um i want paul
thomas anderson
to direct the movie
i want it to star me and daniel day
lewis
i want
a living so
ennio morocconi is out and john berry is
out for score
hmm god that's a tough one
i mean i just had danny elfman on the
podcast maybe it's
he kind of i can't feel like he'd kind
of vibe with paul thomas anderson
although i'm i'm my big lush
romantic score guy
i don't know you know what i gotta go
with hans zimmer i gotta go with hans
zimmer i'm sorry
and we need a co-star i think
do we do jennifer lawrence do we do
jennifer lawrence
me daniel day-lewis jennifer lawrence
i'd go see that movie i'd be in that
movie and then you didn't talk about
writing but somebody's got to write the
damn thing
oh no paul thomas anderson writes
everything so we're done he's he's he's
a true auteur he's a director writer i
love it i didn't have to go
through the sofie's choice of
is it steve's alien or is it aaron
sorkin or alec roth it's perfect we we
saved this that was fun thank you that's
a good movie now we got to figure what
the title of that movie is
somebody call into the lowdown line
with title ideas for this movie please
and then i'll go pitch it in hollywood
you